we finally heard confirmation that Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway broke the law
she violated the Hatch Act at least
twice when she advocated for and against
candidates during that special election
in late 2017 in Alabama between Doug
Jones and Roy Moore ultimately Doug
Jones the winner there and the office of
the Special Counsel which is not the
same thing as Robert Moeller okay office
of the Special Counsel is a different
office put out a report and they said
yeah when Kellyanne Conway advisor to
the president counselor to the President
appeared on television in her official
capacity as White House adviser one time
on CNN one time on Fox News she mixed
official government business and
political views about candidates which
you were not allowed to do and the
office of the special counsel is
advising Donald Trump that there should
be disciplinary action good luck with
that the maximum possible penalty would
be dismissal from her job and a fine of
two years salary and of course Trump
isn't going to do that I can't imagine
and the White House has responded saying
we just don't agree we don't believe she
broke the law they said she was just
there expressing the position of the
president which is that Doug Jones was
not a good candidate and that Roy Moore
was the good candidate and the two
examples include one on Fox & Friends
where she was introduced by the show's
hosts as the counselor to President
Trump she was at the White House during
the interview and she said about Doug
Jones who was the Democratic candidate
down in Alabama folks don't be fooled
he'll be a vote against tax cuts he's
weak on crime weak on borders he's
strong on raising your taxes he's
terrible for property owners now the the
stunning thing is when I first read the
headline Kellyanne Conway violated the
Hatch Act I didn't even think that it
had to do with her comments about the
Alabama special election you might
remember that we covered when Kellyanne
Conway went on Fox News as the counselor
to the president
promoted Ivanka Trump's clothing line
which also arguably is a misuse of that
public position to promote a private
business which by the way is a business
that is connected to the guy who's
sitting in the Oval Office no
repercussions there and I'm not even
really expecting repercussions now
either as I mentioned at the harshest
the penalty would be she loses her job
and she's fine two years pay but since
Trump doesn't fill positions the board
that would decide about Conway's
punishment doesn't have enough people to
reach a quorum so literally we don't
have enough people appointed by Trump to
the board that would decide what
Kellyanne Conway's punishment would be
and of course separate from that Trump
can choose to say that she's got to
leave her role at anytime that he wants
people saying she really didn't break
the law because the worst possible
penalty is firing and find no no she
broke the law it's just that the law is
really weak and the maximum punishment
is really really weak it's so funny when
people go and they say well okay if she
broke the law how much jail time could
she do and well she can't do any jail
time because the maximum penalty is
dismissal from her role and a two year
salary fine oh so it's not like she
really broke the law now she broke the
law there's just almost no penalty for
breaking this law yeah when you think
about it she's the third Trump campaign
manager to break the law in some way
Corey Lewandowski was arrested for
assaulting a reporter but now was
indicted on 12 counts what how did the
Lewandowski thing end up I don't know
what think you know we went unscathed
eventually he was he settled or
something Yeah right yeah I think
eventually look this is not so much
though he's in trouble
no so even still I would say she is the
third campaign manager to at least be
accused of having committed a crime and
then of course whether these things get
settled or whether a Manta fort will do
jail time or whatever I guess we'll wait
and see and listen Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is spot-on with her response she
already said Obama once wore a tan suit
and another time he had Dijon mustard
and there was no punishment nobody cared
at all and nobody should
care about this because it's of no
importance whatsoever today's program is
made possible in part by
fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between
you wager on predictions about
real-world events using futures in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
Eva nonfat or you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at futurecom and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and tons of other topics totally
free available on both Android and iOS
as well as on web browsers that is fut
you you are calm